six one seven eight three zero 4750
we're going to go to our next caller in
the 2-1 for area code caller what's your
name and where you calling from
my name is Trevor from Texas
unfortunately all right what's on your
mind Frank but uh yeah a long time and I
saw segments of you guys of a lot of
color calling it about the other side of
the Civil War debate about whether you
know like whether it weather is about
slavery but I didn't really hear them
articulate what the other side was oh
man I hear it all the time here in Texas
so I'm not sure if it was clarified like
up to that or Kinston but uh if it
hasn't I guess I would like to like say
what it was so so what you're saying is
you are able to state what the other
side's position is on why we had a civil
war for those who don't believe it was
about slavery yes okay what what do they
say okay okay yeah they they assert that
it's about space rights that they
thought that the federal government was
encroaching on the state's ability to
say no we still want slavery and so like
that I mean that that would be tough is
an argument purported like during that
time yeah but it's just like being
picked up I guess in modern time there's
like a valid argument to to make it
about states rights rather than
knowledge slavery so what you're saying
forever is that there are people who
believe that the Civil War wasn't about
slavery it was about states rights to
keep slavery yes okay got it
all right well we've certainly cleared
that up and I think for that we can all
be grateful Turner thanks very much
always great to hear from our viewers in
Texas